hallo leute ich hier ist wieder eure mal
wanne und ich bin nicht allein nicht
hier sondern mit meiner besten freundin
den freund die freundin
ich mache mir das was da drauf steht
heute ist so mein kind das schon sehen
im prinzip muss rein schnell durch zeit
ja youtuber zeichnen habe ich mir das
spiel ausgedacht gibt es das spiel es
kann sein dass das spiel schon gibt
ich habe mir aber spielregeln ausgedacht
und zwar darf jeder drei youtuber
zeichnen und die anderen müssen den
youtuber erwarten wenn du den youtuber
richtig errät bekommst du zwei punkte
und der zeichnet bekommt ein punkt
verraten wurde und was wenn die minuten
abgelaufen ist keiner da wir keine
punkte und marokkanern punkt wie seine
gepaddelt
die bestrafung ist das beste daran ja
eine bestrafung gibt es nicht wir müssen
uns umbringen
der verlierer muss dem gewinner den dieb
kanal übergeben aber habt mehr das ist
unfair
ich bekomme das radio bitte ok ich fange
an oder oder machen wir schnick schnack
schnuck milliarden du bist die
gastgeberinnen bereit weil dann setzt du
dich hier auch alles klar
es gibt muss kann ich da geblieben
ob gott glaubt ihr gebraucht gemacht
wahrscheinlich so einiges aus dem hut
bringt diese frisur nicht mehr deswegen
dachte ich dass eine frau ist sonst
hättest du sofort an
musik wenn man sich dreht ok seite
selber rein
ab dort schätze fertig ok ich würde
erstmal noch kurz zu ende machen kann er
ist ehrlich nicht wichtig dass der dbh
kommt ja jetzt schlafe plätze fertig los
[Musik]
es ist ein eckiger kommen ein plus mit
größer zwei helfer ziehen
what the [ __ ] wer ist denn zwei meter
zehn groß
bist du gut gemacht meinte bergmann
es ist alles was du zeichnest ich dachte
es schon längst vorbei so nein es ist ja
ich habe ein bisschen empfang verkackt
deswegen kann ich jetzt hier nicht mehr
viel da zum zeichnen von normalen
daneben neu an
[Musik]
nein nein das ist ein leader ich dachte
ihr kommt sofort wenn ich jemanden
großes malers david hain ist kann bei
zwei meter 10 ist ja nicht ein meter 10
ich habe halt einen kleinen gedacht weil
das sagt klein aus und dann ich hatte
unterdessen hat jetzt gar keinen punkt
bekommt durchrutschen und
[Musik]
eine kanone wir sind zwei waffen
es ist ein bad ist missbrauchen heute
[Gelächter]
ist die sich nicht blicken nicht ja aber
das ist der echte dahin schreibt der
echte ich nehme jetzt ein bisschen klein
bisschen mehr zeit
das wäre minute ich möchte einfach mal
jetzt ein bisschen das auskosten und
einfach mal ein bisschen durch
künstlerisch ein bisschen was bieten es
geht los
das ist nur backdrop
[Musik]
das macht alles gleich viel mehr sinn da
können wir doch mal wenigstens zwei
punkte hatte ich muss es kürzlich musste
dann wenigstens noch zu ändern diesmal
wollte ja also jedenfalls ungefähr er
ist ja auch ein alien ist das ein
weiterer punkt auf krautchan.net ist
macht ein bisschen sinn ja ich meine
projekte zwei nieren und steven sagt
aber das wird sich auch jetzt für immer
wieder schneit aber jetzt kann ich mir
warum er hat doch kein schweizer
gehrmann ja vielleicht hatte ich dann
wieder andere mussten
[Musik]
okay okay okay es geht los
es geht ja weiter ist sie auch und
gerade also deine hand er du musst so
ein bisschen
[Musik]
wir sind mann mit der brille ist ein
mann mit der brille
es ist die von der 2
[Musik]
hier ist ein markantes kinn españa war
ich zuerst etwas belasten will dieses
war erst wir können das ende in der
storm jetzt los jetzt lauf war dachte
ich du schneidest es kommt die flamme
soll das oder einig zeichnen ihren das
sieht aus wie als ob der nur aus arm
besteht dass ich so ein roboter wie sind
frau steht er aus das spiel gar ihren
körper mehr wer ich muss das noch
perfektioniert hatte hier sind seine
beine
[Gelächter]
ich bin bereits abgelöst
eine mütze es ist ein mittel das ist
nicht nur leute weil das jetzt so
einfach sind verstopft jo jo ich bin
glaube ich wirklich zu gut einfach in
diesem spiel ich geb ich gebe mir mal
kurz ein punkt beim fechten ist er
sicher ok alles und asset und und wir
starten
[Musik]
so bleibst du hier genau das ist jetzt
das ist quasi der anfang
[Musik]
er kennt
okay ich bin erst richtig heißer butter
[Musik]
wartet doch mal so ich wollte ein
bisschen spannender jetzt machen
na ja doch 15
und jetzt ist okay es geht um ihn sein
kumpel ist ein kumpel mit erdgas das
sind also kommt sagt schon weil das eine
schlechte zeichnung mit ist der krebs
und irgendein typ der jeder sein könnte
und kurzfristig hätte glaube ich den
krebs fertig nicht krebs gemeinsam an
krebs das soll klappi darstellen und
sein bester kumpel com
das ist doch ganz allen das ist so zeigt
sich die haare ksv zu sehen sein
das wichtigste nämlich bei k s vergessen
wenn man ihn sofort erkannt hätte der
hat nämlich ein ganz schön heiß
nie im leben drauf gekommen das ist doch
da erkennt man doch so schön der serie
berlin
der ist es andere von den künsten ist
die hände
ich wünsche sehr cool noch mal die augen
[Musik]
war das also unsere rasse weiß er hat
gesagt ich betone mal die augen und weil
ein strich was sind es waren die reds
aber besser machen können das ist
einfach so ein kokon haare machen müssen
zum coco hat doch keinen sinn ich hatte
es hat sich einfach hoch die sind
überall war ihm ja seite jetzt können
sie die highlights bindung solchen so
machen oder was doch die hat überall
habe das ist normal
den löwen körper er ist der könig der
löwen
wunderschön auf dem dritten platz
ersparnis vier punkten gemacht
ich gehe dann auf dem zweiten platz 17
punkte
vanessa und du hast zeit hier möglich
ja ihr seid schlechte verlierer sei die
bestraft wurde ach so wie kriegen kann
also ich keinen kanal stand ich mache
ich mache das nächste das nächste video
bleiben kann
das kannst du jetzt als dies die in
karts machen und jetzt noch hier ein
video klick darauf dann auch noch nicht
darauf hier abonnieren
sacchi land nach schelle bankkonto weißt
du